éteignez chez et ici aussi magali de
l'ampli est ce que vous étiez au courant
de l'existence de ari boulogne que nous
avons reçu ici le fils d'alain delon et
de nico qui est né en 68 centimes à la
période où vous avez rencontré de long
est ce que vous connaissez son existence
bon avant que quand j'ai rencontré alain
oui je sais très bien son existence
puisqu'il n'était pas son fils et
qu'elle s'est pointé au stud en disant
voilà ton fils oui et vous pensez que
c'est passé par oui ou par non voulait
non semapa vaut pas renoncer vous dites
donc vous êtes au courant de l'existence
d'un rite rien vous dit ce n'est pas le
fils d'alain delon voilà je dis ce qui
était vrai cette époque maintenant si
vous pouvez y compterait maintenant je
pouvais rien du tout je vous demande
pourquoi vous l'aimez bien j'ai de la
tendresse pour lui une certaine
compassion pour ce que la vie qu'il a vu
mais je n'ai je vous ai vus tout petit
peu plus tard je ne pense pas que sur le
fils d'alain delon mais attendez je
n'étais pas là ce moment là ce soir là
non non avant employés
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux